Добрий день.
Розпочинаємо урок математики, 5 клас.
Проведу його я, Олена Бурдун.
Тема нашого уроку: «Ділення
десяткового дробу на десятковий дріб».
Але спочатку розв’яжемо наступну задачу.
Представимо умову
задачі у вигляді малюнку.
Нам треба знайти скільки важить
разом груша, слива та яблуко.
Слива та яблуко важать 0,23 кг.
Груша та слива – 0,2 кг.
Груша та яблуко – 0,29 кг.
Такі задачі розв’язуються наступним чином.
Пропоную вам додати ті вирази, які
ми записали під кожним малюнком.
Що ми отримаємо?
2 яблука
додати 2 сливи,
додати 2 груші
і це буде
0,23+0,2+0,29.
Застосуємо властивість
додавання і отримаємо,
що 2 помножимо на суму
яблука, сливи та груші -
і це буде 0,72.
Тепер для того, щоб знайти
суму, яка записана в дужках,
необхідно 0,72 поділити на 2.
Отримаємо, що разом
три фрукти важать 0,36 кг.
Перш ніж перейти до вивчення нової теми,
повторимо, як ми будемо ділити
десятковий дріб на натуральне число.
43,52 поділимо на 17.
Спочатку цілу частину 43
поділимо на 17, візьмемо по 2.
17х2 отримаємо 34, різниця 9.
Зносимо 5.
Оскільки цифра 5 стоїть
уже в дробовій частині,
то в результаті ми повинні поставити кому.
Ділення цілих частин закінчилося.
Тепер 95 треба поділити на 17.
Візьмемо по 5.
17х5 це буде 85,
95-85=1О.
Зносимо 2.
102 поділити на 17, візьмемо по 6.
17х6=102.
Ділення закінчилося.
В результаті отримали 2,56.
Тепер попрацюємо усно
і відпрацюємо наше вміння ділити
десятковий дріб на натуральне число.
Вам треба зменшити десятковий дріб удвічі.
В зошит, будь ласка,
запишіть тільки відповіді.
Впорались?
Перевіримо результат.
2,6:2=1,3;
4,2:2=2,1;
14,6:2=7,3;
1О,8:2=5,4.
Увага на цей приклад: 0,12:2=0,06.
І останній приклад:
0,34:2=0,17.
Молодці. Переходимо до
вивчення нового матеріалу.
Щоб знайти частку двох
десяткових дробів, треба:
Розглянемо, як це правило діє на прикладі.
134,85 треба поділити на 15,5.
У дільнику після коми стоїть одна цифра,
тому ми кому повинні
перенести вправо на одну цифру.
Щоб результат був правильний,
нам необхідно і в діленому кому
перенести вправо на одну цифру.
Отримаємо,
що 1348,5 треба поділити на 155,
на натуральне число, а це
ділення ми вже можемо виконувати.
Спочатку візьмемо по 8.
155х8 це буде 1240.
Знаходимо різницю, буде 108.
Зносимо цифру 5.
Цифра 5 стоїть в дробовій частині,
значить в результаті вже поставили кому.
1085 поділити на 155, візьмемо по 7.
Ділення закінчилося, в
результаті отримали 8,7.
Це остаточний результат нашого ділення.
Попрактикуємось застосовувати правило
ділення десяткових дробів на прикладах.
28,8 поділити на 1,8.
Кому переносимо на один знак вправо
і будемо ділити 288 на 18.
28:18, візьмемо по одному.
Різниця 1О зносимо 8.
Візьмемо по 6.
18 помножити на 6 це буде 108.
Ділення закінчилося, результат 16.
0,72:0,9.
Кому знову переносимо на одну цифру
і будемо 7,2 ділити на 9.
7 на 9 не ділиться, поставили 0 цілих.
72:9, візьмемо по 8.
8х9=72.
В результаті отримали 0,8.
Наступний приклад.
12,88
поділемо на 4,6.
Кому переносимо знову
на одну цифру вправо.
128,8:46.
128:46, візьмемо по 2.
6х2=12 один запам’ятали.
2х4=8 і 1 буде 9.
Знайдемо різницю 6, 3, зносимо 8.
Цифра 8 знаходиться
вже в дробовій частині,
значить в результаті поставили кому.
Ділення цілих частин закінчилося.
368 ми повинні поділити на 46.
Візьмемо по 8.
Отримали 2,8.
Наступний приклад.
0,014
треба поділити на 0,56.
Кому перенесемо на дві цифри.
1,4 будемо ділити на 56.
1 на 56 не ділиться 0 цілих.
14 на 56 також не
ділиться, знову поставили 0.
В кінець дробової частини дописали 0.
140:56, візьмемо по 2.
Знаходимо різницю -
8, 2, можемо дописати 0.
280:56, візьмемо по 5.
56х5 якраз і буде 280.
В результаті отримали 0,025.
81:2,25.
У дільнику кому треба
перенести на 2 цифри вправо.
Зробимо це.
У діленому також треба
перенести кому на 2 цифри вправо.
Де стоїть кома у числі 81?
Правильно, після одиниці.
Ви знаєте, що в дробову частину ми можемо
дописувати нулів стільки,
скільки нам потрібно.
Допишемо два нулі і перенесемо
кому вправо на дві цифри.
Отримаємо
8100:225.
Спочатку 810 поділимо
на 225, візьмемо по 3.
5х3=15,
3х2=6 і один запам’ятовували буде 7.
3х2=6.
Знайдемо різницю буде 5.
Зайняли одну розрядну одиницю, 1О-7=3.
Залишилось замість восьми сім, 7-6=1.
Знесли 0.
1350:225 візьмемо по 6.
6х5=30. 0 записали 3 запам’ятали.
6х2=12 і ще 3 буде 15, один запам’ятали.
6х2=12 і один запам’ятовували буде 13.
В результаті отримали 36.
І останній приклад
1:0,025.
Кому треба перенести на три знаки вправо.
У числі 1 кома стоїть
відразу після 1 цілого.
Допишемо три нулі в дробову частину.
Перенесемо кому на три знаки.
Отримаємо 1000:25.
Ділення 1000 на 25 можна
виконати усно і це буде 40.
І майже на кожному уроці ми
з вами розв’язуємо рівняння.
Розв’яжемо наступні рівняння:
у помножити на 4,9 дорівнює 2,94.
у - невідомий множник.
Щоб знайти невідомий множник,
нам необхідно добуток
поділити на відомий множник,
тобто на 4,9.
2,94:4,9.
Переносимо коми на одну цифру
і буде 29,4:49.
29 на 49 не ділиться, тому 0 цілих.
294:49 візьмемо по 6.
6х9=54,
6х4=24 і додати 5 буде 29.
Чудово. Ділення закінчилося.
І отримали, що у=0,6.
Наступне рівняння.
у : 2,3
дорівнює 5,6.
У даному рівнянні невідомий у
будемо знаходити множенням.
у дорівнює 5,6
помножити на 2,3.
Множення виконаємо в стовпчик.
Нагадую,
що числа підписуємо одне під одним, як
натуральні числа, не зважаючи на кому.
Виконуємо множення також
не звертаючи увагу на кому.
3х6=18, 8 записали і 1 запам’ятали.
5х3=15 і 1 буде 16.
Тепер 2 множимо на 6.
Додаємо: 8, 8, 2, 1.
Порахували скільки цифр стоїть після
коми в обох множниках - дві цифри.
Справа в результаті відрахували
дві цифри і поставили кому.
Отримали 12,88.
Наступне рівняння більш складне,
але ми також його розв’яжемо.
7,8а додати 5,4а дорівнює 3,3.
Спочатку спростимо ліву частину рівняння
і застосуємо розподільну властивість
множення відносно додавання.
(7,8+5,4) і суму цих чисел помножимо на а.
Дорівнює 3,3.
7,8 додати 5,4
це буде 13,2а
дорівнює 3,3.
а - невідомий множник.
Для його знаходження добуток
поділимо на відомий множник.
3,3:13,2
кому перенесли на один знак вправо
і будемо 33 ділити на 132.
33 на 132 не ділиться, 0 цілих.
Дописали в дробову частину 0.
330:132, візьмемо по 2.
Віднімемо 264,
отримаємо 66.
Дописали 0.
660:132, спробуємо взяти по 5.
5х2=1О, 0 записали і 1 запам’ятали.
5х3=15 і 1 - це буде 16.
5х1=5  і 1 - це буде 6.
В результаті отримали, що а = 0,25.
І останнє рівняння.
х-0,28х дорівнює 36.
В лівій частині застосуємо розподільну
властивість множення відносно віднімання.
Якщо ми будемо
застосовувати цю властивість,
то ось на першому місці
замість х залишиться 1
відняти 0,28
помножити на х дорівнює 36.
Якщо ми від 1 віднімемо 0,28
то отримаємо 0,72х = 36.
х будемо знаходити діленням.
36 необхідно поділити на 0,72.
Перенесли кому на дві цифри
вправо і у 36 дописали два нулі.
3600:72.
Будемо ділити 360 на 72, візьмемо по 5
отримаємо 360, а ось цей
0 дописали в результат.
В результаті отримали, що х=50.
Ми з вами добре попрацювали і я
вам пропоную розв’язати логічну задачу.
Ця задача відноситься до
розділу задач на відповідність.
Для того, щоб розв’язати таку задачу
можна використати наступну табличку.
Поки я буду креслити табличку,
спробуйте самостійно розв’язати задачу.
А потім перевіримо вашу відповідь з моєю.
По горизонталі ми напишемо назви посудин.
У нас є пляшка,
склянка,
глечик
і банка.
І є наступні рідини:
молоко,
лимонад,
квас
і вода.
Тепер уважно читаємо умову задачі.
Відомо, що вода і молоко не в пляшці.
Молоко і вода не може
знаходитися в пляшці.
Посудина з лимонадом стоїть між глечиком,
значить лимонад вже
знаходиться не в глечику.
Лимонад не в глечику.
І посудиною з квасом -
квас також не в глечику.
А в банці ні лимонад, ні вода.
Читаємо далі умову задачі.
Склянка стоїть біля банки
і посудини з молоком.
Значить, молоко знаходиться
не в склянці, і не в банці.
Тепер ми можемо точно сказати
яка рідина знаходиться в якій посудині.
Молоко знаходиться в глечику,
значить вода не може знаходитись в
глечику, і вода знаходиться в склянці.
Квас знаходиться в банці,
лимонад знаходиться в пляшці.
Якщо ви хочете вдома
потренуватися розв’язувати такі задачі,
то запишіть, будь ласка,
умову наступної задачі.
Сподіваюсь, що у вас вийде
знайти правильну відповідь.
Підсумуємо наш урок.
Лунає дзвоник, до побачення.